if you're an entrepreneur small business
owner or salesperson today's video is
for you last week I'm giving a keynote
in La Granada Hills California to about
two 300 loan officers and Realtors and I
open it up with asking the question
what's keeping you up at night one of
the ladies on this side raises her hand
and she says Pat my phone is no longer
ringing the way it was six to 12 months
ago and my answer to her shocked the
entire crowd but it's exactly what I
needed to hear so if you get value out
of today's video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let me get
right into it today's sponsor is Aura
what Aura does is protect you against
identity theft which today it is the
fastest growing crime in all of America
just last year 1.5 million Americans
experience identity theft for you know
how much money ready not one billion not
5 billion not 10 billion 52 billion
dollars just last year every 14 seconds
somebody's identity is stolen which
means during this video four to five
people's identity will be stolen and the
reason why this is important to me is
I've been in the financial industry for
a long time Insurance Finance we spend a
lot of money every year to protect
against cyber security attacks just a
fun fact one of our employees Aaron went
on their website and he tested to see
how many times his identity had been
stolen his passport over 40 times on the
dark web you may want to find out how
many times your identity has been stolen
so if you want to protect yourself from
the fastest growing crime in America
visit aura.com forward slash value
timing to start your 14-day trial one
more time Aura
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14-day free trial with aura
try Aura free for two weeks to find that
if any of your personal information or
your family's personal information has
been compromised I'm in La I asked this
question she says Pat my phone's no
longer rinking the moment she says that
to me I went back to the 21 year old pbd
selling at Valley Total Fitness in
Culver City visually I'm there I'm
sitting in a corner with a couple
thousand names of people that have come
into the gym before for me to call
Francisco Davis is sitting here Dexter
McClendon you know Danny Molino Joey
Reyes Sylvia Reyes Ruben rimmer Lemo
watt Donna Barney I got everybody that
I'm looking I knew I remember everything
about this place one month
I'm like how come no one's coming to buy
a membership from me how come I'm not
getting any walk-ins how come I'm not
getting any telephone inquiries no one
was buying from me and I go to Cisco I
said I don't think the sales thing's for
me he said listen you got to know one
thing here I said what's that he says no
one's going to call you
because you're not big yet
you're going to do a lot of calling
until people call you it says don't
worry about
people calling you dial I told her I
said you don't have a people calling you
problem you have a dialing out problem
the people that make it in sales no
matter what the economy is good bad and
ugly are the ones that if we were to
pull up their report on their phones
and you see the report on their phones
they call out more than people call in
do you know why because you control your
destiny I'm calling out I'm dying I'm
prospecting I'm calling how you doing
John Mary what do you think about the
current economy what's keeping you up at
night what do you think about what's
going on with real estate did you see
what John Powell did with the raids
another half a point went up how do you
process this what do you think about
this I'm calling them let me tell you
what I'm hearing from the experts here's
what we know we don't know anything
anybody that tells you anything they
don't know anything whatever I tell you
in regards to this I also don't know
anything all I can tell you is here's
what seven experts have said Buffett
said this this person said this
Bloomberg said this B of A said the city
said this Goldman Sachs said this Morgan
Stanley said this so the truth is
probably somewhere right there based on
that here's what I suggest we do but I'm
calling here's the reality if I call and
my competitors are probably not going to
call guess who wins I'm at Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter 911 happens prior to
that if you walked into Morgan Stanley
Dean Withers Glendale often his ninth
floor I believe it was so loud
everyone's on the phone that said
looking sharp three-piece suit boom
calling talking 9 11 happened silence no
one's calling silence the next day no
one's calling the following day 9 13 no
one's calling 9 14. no one was calling
anybody they were frightened until one
day they sat us down and they said hey
guys the guy in the corner frightened of
the phone he says look here's two issues
you got some of you are afraid customers
are calling in the stock Brokers were
not answering the phones they were
afraid to answer the phones because they
knew the client's gonna say I just lost
eight hundred thousand dollars I just
lost 300 000 I just lost 2.8 million
dollars what are we going to do with my
money they were so afraid but the people
that made it long term were the ones
that made the calls and they said before
you call me Johnny I wanted to be
proactive and I wanted to call you
here's what's going on the industry
right now most people are not answering
their calls by their clients and most
people are not making the calls to their
clients I just want to tell you I'm in
this business long term and I'm here to
call you and tell you what I think is
going on this is a scary site for a lot
of different people but we're going to
go through this together do you know
what that phone say you got two people
one makes that phone call the other one
doesn't make that phone call who do you
think is winning long term they got
making a phone call this is the season
of those who are proactive this is the
season of those who are building
relationship this is the season of those
who play offense and go talk to the
clients make the calls not waiting for
everybody to call them if you only DM if
you only text if you only send emails
today that's the season of the cowards
if you call or do Zoom or face to face
that's the season of leaders and
everybody in the marketplace is going to
reward leaders in today's economy
especially
in 2023 so if you
want to stand out
in 2023 be proactive pick up the phone
make the call
make the zoom and even better
go see them face to face they're going
to respect your courage and they're
going to say babe there's one thing I
know about Johnny
Larry Mary
he or she's in Atlanta we're working
with the right person fantastic glad to
hear while everybody else like
cockroaches disappears from the industry
you become a leader that's all of a
sudden a person goes from making 120 per
year to 890 from a small business doing
1.8 million year to 7.2 in times like
2022 2023. having said that I got
another video I want you to watch
specifically if you're in real estate
and Loans it's a video about seven
things you can do to stand out during
this scary times in the real estate
industry if you've never seen a click
here to watch it if you got value from
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye